bonjour et bienvenue à villars sur ollon
avec une vraiment magnifique but encore
une fois comme ça en suisse et
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de ce
qui est la raison principale je pense
pour laquelle les débats tournent
souvent si mal à savoir l'auto promotion
et la barbe et au nez de clown il dit
comme ça ça peut paraître évident l'auto
promotion c'est assez clairement mal ça
fait en sorte que les égos prennent le
dessus
finalement c'est l'expression même des
ego que cette idée d'auto promotion et
bien sûr c'est quelque chose que qui est
extra nouvelle puisque ça focalise
l'attention sur les individus et ça
encourage les attaques ad hominem
et puis même juste et ses points de vue
très personnel et ça leur empêche par
exemple de donner l'importance au
consensus scientifique un scientifique
est la hêtraie est également ça donne
moins d'importance aux arguments puisque
l on reste très souvent l'impression que
ce qui compte c'est que la personne qui
est soit la plus légitime parce que
c'est la plus légitime a parlé on a
l'impression que c'est elle qu'il faut
écouter pour particulière mettant en
avant les individus et souvent beaucoup
d'admiration soie brute de haine envers
certains individus qui apparaît et
rapidement on en vient à parler des
individus et sont défendables admirable
et à cinq ans ou moins longues et
dénonce que ces personnes deviennent des
symboles et qu'il faut défendre ou
détruire et très clairement ce réflexe
initial d'auto promotion peut conduire à
de très mauvaise tournure d'énormément
et ses problèmes de d'auto promotion
sont particulièrement seyante dans des
débats où on a l'impression qu'il faut
absolument avoir une espèce d'autorité
pour pouvoir parler de donner son avis
et c'est typiquement le cas notamment
dans les débats
qui ont à voir avec la morale ou
typiquement il ya ces élections en tout
cas il faut encore anglophones qui
consiste à dire avoir le morro live band
être un peu au dessus moralement et ils
sont souvent dans ce genre de discussion
qu'il faut être au-dessus moralement
pour apporter quelque chose de
constructif au débat et il me semble
malheureusement que c'est un très
mauvais réflexe bien dans le compteur il
ya beaucoup de choses à apprendre et
compris de se voir peut-être même
surtout de ceux qui réfléchissent à
morales et qui sont pas contents de leur
statut moral et qui donc chercher à
progresser moralement
là c'est une phase assez intéressante
puisque ces gens là vous justement
peut-être créé en plus de chances de se
poser la question de comment être
davantage moral pour rien versé bien sûr
c'est pas parce qu'on est dans ce genre
de situation qu'il faut le mettre en
avant et qu'on à l'autorité morale je
pense que sur ce genre de débat surtout
quand ça a à voir avec la morale c'est
important de faire gaffe à ne pas faire
d'auto promotion à ne pas montrer qu'on
est supérieurs moralement à l'autre car
après à chacun va vouloir montrer que
moralement il est supérieur à l'autre on
a des digues débat sur même moi je fais
si moi je recycle moi je machin chose
et finalement c'est pas forcément les
questions de plus intéressant de la
morale les questions à une intéressante
mais ne sont pas nécessairement ce que
chacun fait mais plutôt ce que chacun
pourra faire par exemple pour que le
monde est mieux que j'ai ce comme ça
notre sujet qui a vraiment casse gueule
je vous prie de faire vraiment preuve de
tant de bienveillance que possible et gc
- était-ce vraiment bienveillant quand
je dis ça c'est le fait que lorsqu'on
parle encore une fois de débats de
problèmes moraux notre temps des
problèmes dont certaines personnes sont
victimes dans la société
on a tendance à donner plus de
légitimité à la personne qui est victime
de ce phénomène et d'essai revenir
c'est pas complètement à tort puisque
cette personne a été victime donc c'est
elle qui est finalement le centre
intérêts et qui devrait donc on devrait
faire en sorte que la situation
s'améliore néanmoins il me semble pas
clair que juste parce qu'une personne
est victime et que son message sera plus
légitime plus bénéfique y compris à la
personne elle même
bien souvent quand on est victime de
quelque chose on a tendance à être dans
un état émotionnel acea s'est accentuée
d'avoir une vision assez biaisée de la
situation en tout cas voir assurément
selon notre propre point de vue et du
coup il se pourrait que pour tout cas
dans de nombreux cas il me semble qu'il
ya vraiment à gagner à avoir un regard
extérieur qui vient aider corroborer et
réfléchir à comment mieux penser le
problème est surtout à quelle action
entreprendre pour que la situation de la
personne victime 5 milliards autant que
possible et surtout que ce qui lui
arrive et n'arrivent plus à d'autres
victimes potentielles
mais du coup ça veut pas dire que sur
ces débats c'est pas parce qu'une
personne fait partie notamment du groupe
social
qui est victime qu'elle devrait être
celle qu'on devrait le plus écouté c'est
assez bizarre c'est contre intuitif mais
finalement des gens qui ont bien
comprennent bien la situation et ont des
réflexions plus poussées peuvent mériter
plus attention idéalement en bon bien
sûr forêt
les deux équipes combinaison des deux
est justement pour qui une combinaison
de gens qui ont un regard extérieur qui
réfléchissent bien et des gens
acquisition victime et qui savent ce
qu'ils ont vécu les choses de
l'intérieur
il faut absolument qu'il se voir de
combien de dialogue entre ces personnes
pour pouvoir mieux comprendre et c'est
vrai que le débat tourne mieux de savoir
de situation est vraiment très important
de mais c'est extrêmement difficile car
souvent les personnes notamment qui ont
été victimes se sentent mérité plus de
légitimité et du coup son auto promotion
de la gravité de leur situation ou de
leur cas particulier
et ça ça me semble pas toujours
totalement constructif au débat ou en
tout cas nous semble parfois qu'on peut
faire mieux dans l'optique de bâton bio
et de la même façon que lorsqu'on en est
victime qui annoncé comme plus que les
jours où tout cas on sait des choses que
les autres personnes n'ont pas ne savent
pas ça reste une connaissance ou
supplémentaires et du coup une valeur en
plus dans le débat est donc ça peut
valoir le coup de mettre en avant cela
mais faut vraiment pas trop insister
dessus parce qu'encore une fois c'est
pas parce qu'on est victime qu'on
comprend tout la situation est encore
moins que l'on comprend exactement ce
qu'il faudrait faire
et c'est l'occasion ici de parler avec
d'autres personnes de la même façon
lorsque l'on se positionne experts d'un
domaine lorsqu'on a beaucoup appris un
domaine il va c'est un peu dangereux de
mettre trop cela en avant puisqu'il ya
un an de bière chez les experts
notamment il ya sur pas mal de questions
qui sont pas directement le sujet des
expertises de l'expert donc typiquement
si je prendrai un expert en ia il n'est
pas expert des prédictions on est
typiquement probables en écho n'est pas
très bien de l'histoire des prédictions
on y avoir dans pratique beaucoup
d'expérience il ignore complètement
sauvage qui a eu lieu en 2015 quand même
auprès des experts en est un expert en
est à cons
et espère de tout ce qui a à voir avec
l'irs et s'est du coup important de
faire attention à ça et de ne pas du
coup mettre trop en avant son expertise
pour s'habituer à se mettre dans une
situation de modestie systémique et
surtout pour éviter que les débats ne
tourne en bataille de qui a le plus
d'autorité de crédibilité ou de
légitimité pour parler de tel ou tel
sujet je trouve ça vraiment dommage
qu'on ait débat en arrive là je vous
préfère a bien sûr des débats qui fasse
en sorte que tout le monde se met à
réfléchir et à mieux réfléchir et qu'ils
fassent émerger des idées les plus
convaincantes les arguments les plus
comme telling du point qu'en et les
données qui devraient changer les
positions des uns et des autres et du
coup plutôt que de se battre pour avoir
ce statut de la personne légitimer la
personne qu'il faut écouter
je trouve ça intéressant de temps en
temps de faire contre un peu le
contre-pied et d'insister sur le fait
que chacun d'entre nous ben on a nos
limites nos connaissances et de
régulièrement rappelée typiquement
l'étendue de notre propre ignorance est
une façon de faire soit efficace et
d'insister sur ces marqueurs de modestie
épistémique sur lequel on reviendra dans
la prochaine vidéo en particulier il me
semble très souhaitable de faire preuve
autant que possible d'autodérision de
mettre en avant ses propres erreurs de
dire à quel point on est ignorant au
moins une fois de temps en temps est ce
possible
je pense que c'est une bonne chose ça
devient un truc assez régulier assez
récurrent est typiquement pour finir sur
un truc un peu mieux et a acheté agm
état de meta je trouve que c'est quelque
chose que je fais pas vraiment très bien
encore justement ça va constamment
essayé de mettre un peu plus en avant un
truc exemplaire que j'ai fait et je vais
essayer à l'avenir de mettre un peu plus
en avant les bêtises tout toutes les
bêtises que je fais et toutes les
bêtises que je pense et c'est de mettre
en avant l'étendue de ma stupidité et
d'ailleurs sans plus tarder en voici un
exemple embarrassant à savoir le premier
enregistrement de ma conclusion de cette
vidéo
je pense qu'une bonne chose ça devient
un truc assez régulier assez récurrent
en tout cas c'est un truc que j'essaie
de faire de souligner les erreurs que je
fais de souligner l'étendue mon immense
j'ai failli finir cette vidéo contre
auto promotion par une auto promotion